bueno hace tiempo digamos en mi infancia
temprana mi papá no creía en tener una
televisión en casa porque no quería que
yo perdiera mi tiempo viendo las
caricaturas de los sábados por la mañana
pero me encantan las caricaturas la
caligrafía y la habilidad manual eran
increíbles así que esa fue la
inspiración y se convirtió en
entretenimiento para mí digamos
simplemente me encanta saber pasar el
tiempo dibujando tienes algunos ejemplos
digamos fotos o algo del trabajo
artístico que hiciste en esos tiempos
yo podría si tengo tengo obras en casa
que puedo desenterrar y supongo bueno
estaría avergonzado de mostrarlas pero
las mostraré de todas formas porque
quienes andan por ahí viendo este vídeo
todos ustedes son mis amigos
sabes el arte es algo que todos
comenzamos desde un lugar en el que nos
sentimos sensibles al respecto pero
simplemente lo sigues haciendo lo
disfrutas y te mejoras en eso es una de
esas cosas que se cumplen por sí mismas
construí mi propia computadora cuando yo
tenía unos 12 o 13 años australia iba a
dominar la industria informática con una
computadora llamada micro bit así que
proseguía construir esta micro bit y
luego cómo podía programar podía así
crear personajes con ella uno de los
sistemas de juego más populares de
entonces se llamaba alliance que
traducido al español significa que
extraterrestres entonces uno de los
primeros programas que hice fue uno con
extraterrestres que atravesaban la
pantalla y les podía disparar y usábamos
una cosa llamada gráficos de sprites de
que viene del inglés duendecillos y fue
muy emocionante para mí ya no tener que
pagar por este juego podía crear luego
por mí mismo y disfrutarlo yo era una
persona poco común que hacía tanto arte
como matemáticas cuando entré a la
universidad busque obtener un título en
matemáticas y otro en ingeniería y
recibí una doble titulación pero me
apasionaba en las artes así que en la
noche me ponía a pintar a dibujar y
dedicaba a mi tiempo a mejorarme en eso
ya en el día aprendía matemáticas y ese
era el momento perfecto porque la
computación gráfica iba del lado técnico
y del lado artístico también
bueno para nuestro proyecto final hice
un sistema de animación que animaba las
leyes de la relatividad especial estaba
yo muy entusiasmado por mostrar estos
nuevos graf y fui presente allí mi
trabajo y mientras yo estaba ahí dos
personas de pixar presentaron un pequeño
cortometraje llamado looks o junior y el
corto tenía sabes la lámpara que todos
hemos visto saltar y fui a ver el corto
y vi la lámpara y me dije a mí mismo eso
es lo que quiero hacer
y durante dos grados cuando di la
presentación de mi sistema de animación
bill read si john lasseter se acercaron
a alentarme de una forma realmente
apreciable tenían muchas preguntas
excelentes sobre el sistema que escribí
nos divertimos mucho presentando lo
porque dibujamos bueno conseguimos una
tarjeta y podíamos desplazarnos a
velocidades cercanas a la velocidad de
la luz y fueron muy alentadores no solo
con mi interés artístico sino también
con el lado matemático que hacía que
esta cosa fuera posible tú fuiste el que
articuló a sol y cierto si así es puedes
contarnos sobre la articulación de sol y
sol y fue mi primera me emocioné mucho
articulando al sol y porque él era un
personaje super expresivo él tenía peso
volumen tenía pelo y tenía una cara muy
ancha de la que tuvimos que obtener una
amplia gama de expresiones y estábamos
intentando averiguar qué controles
podíamos hacer para expresar realmente
el personaje mostraba una gama completa
de emociones así que necesitábamos no
sólo la parte artística para hacerlo
necesitábamos muchos nuevos de
formadores algo similar a lo que hemos
creado en este tutorial y bueno esto era
un proyecto fascinante para mí ahí
estaba yo crea
un personaje que realmente yo confiaba
que podría establecer una conexión con
la gente y que se convertiría en un
personaje muy querido
por el momento estoy fascinado con la
piedra estoy ya sabes simplemente
tallando piedra y es difícil y tengo un
aprecio increíble por las personas que
hicieron esas asombrosas esculturas hace
siglos en la época del renacimiento
porque digo me encuentro solo haciendo
esto y pienso cómo es que lo lograron
pienso en la tremenda habilidad y el
trabajo tan duro que se necesitan para
hacer eso y para mí es increíble también
el año pasado hicimos una bobina de
tesla y la bobina de tesla dispara
chispas a través del jardín trasero y
tratamos de hacer malvaviscos con
nuestra bobina de tesla puede una bobina
de tesla azar malvaviscos tendrás que
construir una para averiguarlo
advertencia advertencias
así